what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning tea thoughts before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
subscribe to the channel so
today I want to be talking about
I am going to be talking about the
Dynamics between men and women but in a
different way
so
um
maybe maybe the same way if someone's
probably made a video like this before
but but okay
so I was thinking about how much my
little brother
Adam and my dad do for me
and actually now that I think about it
Austin my other brother
also really helped me when I was in
Milwaukee because I used to live in
Milwaukee for a little bit and so did he
like
he would help me move all these times
and like I don't know I was just
thinking about
how much the men in my life do for me
and it kind of not to say the women in
my life don't right I mean
but especially the guys like with men
it's just different when they help you
they not like women will throw back in
your face and say oh all I did for you
and they'll come back and just like list
all the things they did for you and like
it kind of takes like the genuineness of
it when you know you're mad at me
and you yell at me I mean I'm sure the
men have experiences I'm sure I've done
this you know I'm not even saying I'm
better than anyone
Okay so
it's gonna burn me if I drink it it's
gonna burn me okay
so
that happens right they like parents so
I'll give you an example when I first
started the business
um the channel and everything like I
started actually making real money I
didn't keep any of it I was really bad
with spending
um because I bought a producer right
away I bought like I really just spent
it on people and from a business mind I
guess that makes more sense you know
you're buying your time so you
personally can invest into the business
I was just tired and I wanted to sleep
again
so you know it was like we started
making money in like May
um
July
I bought a recruiter
I think may I bought a producer
June
I bought an assistant
so I just like the first thing I did was
bought people but the problem was
one it was super disorganized I was
paying people on different cards I was
buying things on different cards and
like I had to look back and everything
was just a mess from the past like six
months
and my brother spent hours and hours of
his time organizing it with me sorting
stuff
um getting people on the same pay
structure because some people were paid
like a percentage of the ad like revenue
on a show like some people were like it
was just like a mess and he was like we
have to salary people we have to do this
my dad and my brother did this and my
accounting was so messed up
and I wanted to get an accountant but
they told me no and I just kind of
listened to them even if I disagree
because I'm like they know more clearly
I
I'm a mess and
so so
um
I was just like thinking on the plane
just like how much
my brother my dad and my other brother
Austin they they have done for me and
they continuously do for me and I was
thinking I'm like I wish I gave them
more in return and I feel bad about this
sometimes like they do so much for me
and it's like what can I offer even my
dad on Christmas I was like what can I
offer the man that has everything is
everything I made him a video of
everyone like saying nice things about
it that's what I did but
oh that's so hot okay
um
and what I realized is men
will go to the ends of the Earth for you
they will help you so much and all they
want back is respect and honor
and it's kind of wild to us as women
exemplary I would want more back if I
did that all I did was my brothers is I
make them cookies when I'm home I'm
actually even kind of messy it's not
good it's a negative trait of mine
and
I was like Dad if I move home if I cook
for you and make you guys cookies all
the time can I move home I'm sorry I
know I'm a little messy I'm probably
still gonna be messy I'll work on it and
it's funny because they're like oh
the cookies are good that I'm an okay
cook I make very good I'm a good Baker I
am a good Baker
um
and
so that's what I mean like men
oh
will do so much for you and they will
help you they don't really want anything
when returned but respect and honor
because both of my brothers my dad and
my brother now
that I speak like so crazy high of them
um like I'm always talking about how
much they help me and my little brother
Adam I always tell him that he is going
to be my richest sibling and like you
know some siblings don't like because I
make more than him technically now right
I don't really count it because Adam's
like learning from my dad and my dad's
going to teach him how to run a company
like Adam could go run Amazon if he
wanted to Adam is like
he's creative
he's a big picture thinker and he's
disagreeable enough to run a team
and I don't have that I could never
myself run a 200 person company I
struggle with the 10 people roughly 10
to 15 that I have
I struggle
immensely with that I wouldn't even want
it to be bigger than that even though it
could I my dream would be to work with
my dad or my brother but they don't want
to
because they're starting a software
company together and like that's that's
their dream you know this is mine and
yeah I don't know
um so I was just thinking about how men
are happy to do things for you and all
you really have to do is say and I don't
do this intentionally intentionally or
maliciously or like
say these things because I want
something in return I say this stuff
about them because I mean it and as a
girl all you have to do is say
thank you so much
my brother or husband or whoever it is
is the best
make them food when they want it you
know I just make them cookies whenever
they want it that's my thing and like
honestly they're happy campers it's
really weird to us because as women
we're not happy campers like we can have
everything and we're still not happy
campers
but that's the thing about men is like
they want to help you
they want to be that guy that they let
like you go to for advice and for help
with like your problems
that's what they want
and they want to be someone that you
look up to enough to like
ask for help like like I look up to my
little brother he's little
like I was better than him and most
things grown up honestly he was two
years younger than me two and a half I
don't have two I have to two and a half
roughly
um
and when we were little like we were
competitive about stuff but the older I
got like I don't know what happened but
the dynamic just changed to the point
where I was like I really look up to him
um
like I remember when I started running
when I was a kid okay so I was a runner
and I always wanted to do things that my
siblings didn't because I always wanted
to be like good at something that my
siblings were and I would always get mad
because I was the oldest girl so I grew
up like in a house of six I have ten
total but the four came either before or
after when I was in the house when I was
in the house I had six I was the oldest
girl
my mom would just sign the other kids up
for whatever I signed up for so I signed
up for running
one year I signed up for Vault and my
mom put my brother in it I was so mad
because my brother went on to be like
third in the nation in his age group for
running and I was just like I just
wanted to be good at running so then I
quit running and I did volleyball and
that's all my sisters and
I did basketball my mom puts all I was
just like so mad like I used to get so
mad about this but it's funny
I don't know when the dynamic changed
with my brother because I used to be
competitive with him I mean I had to
have been if you know he I was mad he
joined the running team but some Dynamic
changed where I was just like you know
I'm just unbelievably proud of him
he's gonna be richer than I ever will
he's going to do more and like impact
the world in ways that like
I
I mean who knows I mean you know YouTube
is like
a different animal but
it's not like I hope he does I hope he
like I hope he runs for president I hope
he like
builds what I don't know because
I I'm just really proud of him
and like I can think of so many times
where like oh my gosh there's this time
I don't remember how old I was I was in
my early 20s and I was just I get to
this point where sometimes I'm always
I've always been a busy person and I've
always maybe taken on like more than I
should sometimes like this year I got my
Master's Degree I'm playing Semi-Pro
volleyball
and and I started a YouTube channel and
um I think that's sometimes my fault is
I just like to do and oh and I've been
doing guitar lessons twice a week and as
I as sometimes I really like to and I've
been learning to cook this year it's
like I really like to push myself and I
really like to get good at things and I
really just have always enjoyed being
like skilled at things
and
um
I'm learning that's more of a masculine
trait which probably isn't good I don't
know but um
but I remember this time where it was a
similar situation as to I was in last
year so like when I went to my brother
and I was just like I have all the
expenses
I'm losing track of who I need to pay
what I'm overpaying these people like it
was just a mess and this was a different
time where my car was just such a mess
it was so messy and my room was a mess
and it was like I can't remember what I
had going on but it was like
I was doing like 10 things at once and
Adam just spent the whole day
oh it was when I was working at the
startup that's what it was I was working
at the startup for plumbing Tech
long story different day but
I was with Adam and he just saw how
stressed I was and it's like he just
spent the whole day helping me now if a
woman helped me with that she would be
the first to like rub it in my face to
throw it in later but for whatever
reason like Adam just
he he never even mentioned it again like
I never heard about it again and that's
the thing about men is they just want to
be honored and I see my sister sometimes
because they'll have Adam is just like
a bull by the horns like
it's Adam's way or it's the highway
right like you can't
I put this like
if Adam says we're going down door a we
are going down door a it doesn't matter
if you want to go down door B or C or D
we are going down door a and sometimes
my sisters can have an issue with that
because Adam's a big bossy
but I don't really mind being bossed
around I just have okay and sometimes
he's wrong and sometimes he's right and
sometimes my dad's wrong and sometimes
they're right but
my whole point is I
get more help from Adam
and I get along better with Adam because
I don't argue with him
and tell him why I'm right and I don't
try to compete with him all I do is just
say how proud of him I am and really
support what he's doing and like I think
I think I'm gonna get my period I'm
getting like emotional but and really
just like
yeah I'm just like genuinely proud of
him
and same with my dad
um I just like look up to both of them
and I'm proud of them and I think
sometimes women like this reminds me of
the way we interact with men because
when we get competitive with them it's
like they hate us they hate us for it
we're not built to compete like men are
honestly on YouTube like I look at it as
I'm having fun
um I mean don't get me wrong there's
certain metrics I wanted to hit and ways
I wanted to compete but I'm not
like motivated like the way everyone
else is like
I just want to make cool and interesting
content
that maybe shows some of the double
standards in our society
um
you know
so
I don't know if this made any sense this
I say this every coffee talks I'm so
scatterbrained I don't script these out
or anything I just talk but it's like
when you support the men
they will do more for you and they will
help you get to where you want to go to
and I think a lot of times women would
get further working with their husbands
and working with their brothers and
working with their fathers and competing
with them because I know I could not
have taken the channel to where it's at
without the help of my dad and my
brothers
I every business decision that I make I
really call them
everything I do I call them and I ask
their opinions and I really don't make I
can't think of any decision that I've
really made where I didn't involve them
so
that's
that's what I wanted to say
um with men ladies if we trust them
support them
they will do more for you and help you
get to where you want to go a lot of
guys
we'll help you follow your dreams too if
you don't treat them like the they are
these people that are out to get you
because they're not
um
in a different situation my brothers
could have been very competitive with me
where
if I was rubbing my success in their
face to them rubbing the money I make in
their face to them
but instead
I just talk about how they I couldn't
have gotten there without them and talk
about how they're going to do better
than me someday
and I like that Dynamic a lot better so
that's just my
my personal yeah so let me know in the
comments what you guys think subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell I'll talk to you next time